how dare you leave me alone say can't
even look at you how can you see nudity
speak a kid why are you so angry
what is he writing I like you more as a
duck okay I like the cat with a
ballerina dress in the background oh
come on you gotta be positive sometimes
know how Ellen then we're gonna defeat
this game what the [ __ ] are you doing
run like you have diarrhea hey red mana
you're supposed to take the other side
let's have a little my life I do not
want Oh what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing my dad died i
drowning in the lava
nice going Ken take this from speciated
boat let's go ken yeah take me bird come
on go come on let's go hey Oh No gonna
die now but like I need to be faster
otherwise something bad oh yeah
it happened oh okay cool
yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] oh go go go go go
go go go
I don't know what to do there okay what
about no why did you do that you're
supposed to go across so you get yeah
but don't throw me when I'm not ready
hey what'd you throw a man when he's not
ready gone here gonna always be ready
gone Wow
I'm just gonna sleep here oh my god I'm
getting there like you're buying Wow
it's really hard
can we not do it now oh come on you got
a time to [ __ ] just awesome yeah okay
let me jump [ __ ] all right okay fine
you know what it [ __ ] fine died you
said let you jump well no let me jump
what do you think let me [ __ ] jump
means God God
you're not gonna do good a job see what
the [ __ ] that left me and yeah are you
wasted another one already just add
[ __ ] there and jump but I want you to
jump oh you want me to jump now nobody
any job what I want you to jump okay I
can't take this you are free face piece
for everyone God our teamwork is the
worst so you fall you have an ego
problem
okay we can do this I'm sorry I'm so
sorry I didn't mean that
Oh Maura but stop jump on my face to
progress okay this is not cool I would
I'm getting real tired of your [ __ ] game
I'm asleep everywhere so you're gonna
get us a boat now yeah good job on that
part you messed it all up I messed it
all up
I missed that on my handle then you're
like look at this it blew up that's like
wow all right well who got out of the
bird Phil in my face Oh Peter bunny
crush man please please get the bird
back for me I'm all alone okay we can do
this no we can I jump when I say you
know jump jump good job see you didn't
even hit my head on that one okay so
stay right there okay huh oh wow yeah
I'm pressing stop blowing them up for
you Ken okay oh hi what are you doing
throwing me like that ain't nobody throw
me we had it just get over there get it
stop fighting it what are you doing
catch me then what you have a problem
you set up throwing me look okay Toby oh
my god we made it it's crazy
oh yeah you're welcome
oh no we need one more i numbed ready
okay so much jelly
oh you know what I'm gonna wait over
here leaves you I can't make it now come
on
[ __ ] I think I climbed the jelly
frisbee how do I climb made this tea
jumpin Oh God how do I climb the jelly
help man you [ __ ] see what am I
supposed to do spam the jump oh all of
them what did you do what was best dark
time for the boat now and oceans here's
a boat we talking about here we're in
tonight in the bud
yeah that's how I can go now this part
[ __ ] this part you really have to spam
it I didn't know that oh yeah that I'm
you can do it okay yeah you better go
back where I'm gonna have one minute Oh
Carmen I'm not the government hi this I
missed the Garmon that's okay I got it I
got it
no I don't got it I got it
yeah yeah ah finally
yeah it was so easy I got an achievement
you did it alright it's about two more
until okay the kitty cat okay I don't
know what we do here
you don't know it's obvious one of us
has to die for the other I'll die for
you double my face that was actually the
case that's Larry bullshitting
alright yeah good job we can just go
again
and that went better oh hello can you
dick I'm sorry okay I forgive and that's
all right I'm sorry
Hey well then you say you're sorry sorry
how sorry kind of sorry not sorry big
sorry
Hey okay okay that's it
well someone has to sacrifice again okay
I'll be the sacrifice er
thanks Ken you're welcome Oh
oh no the boat is coming yeah come here
boo did not yeah wow that was a lot
easier then look what okay we only have
one more Wow a plus plus wow so good
that's Jesus
yeah we're so good obviously everyone
knows one seat number one don't wanna do
an ad a thank you thank you thank you
thank you
all right I'm gonna do that too you know
yeah double stop doing me okay goose
it'll do you have a timer yes go on
quite a bad mood King oh really
oh don't want to risk it for the team
can
can I say I'm a team here I'm so mad at
it right now I'm peering right into it
smack it smack it now that was not part
of it fine oh good now that what it was
that was deep I gotta tell you over
there come here okay don't do anything
open now why did I say I did it I did it
Oh angry sometimes you get so mad
Oh God you scare me just go in with that
McCain kids come on come on come on with
your fighting spirit [ __ ] how am I
supposed to get up there I'm not an
astronaut I don't want to add it all
this yeah I think you just go able to
cut out really big jump yeah now what
what about me yeah yeah help me up
you go up yeah and then help me up and
then go just go just go to think about
it just do what your body likes do oh my
god oh my god no I'm dying but it's okay
it's a game we made yeah oh yes [ __ ]
this kitty over this is not an A+ I'm
gonna be pissed
oh yeah cuz you miss one you missed one
SUSE no you didn't mm-hmm of course I
didn't know yeah you did
yeah what happens now something cool
something cool something cool better
happen where is my tiara
you have to change your head size it is
my god I'm sure I've never seen
something so beautiful what was that
there's a love letter ah that is trash
how about you don't kill me for a second
okay thank you oh whoa how do you do
that Wow right trigger stop climbing
it's not crazy touch my butt yeah hey
let's let our budget touch each other's
butt this game a 10 out of 10 again I'm
doing a hand slide waltz work yeah oh my
god let me do it that over here let's
just walk
hey I think I need to throw it from here
tap it out sorry okay